[Musica]
[Applauso]
che cosa significherà essere un
passeggero nel futuro che tipo di mezzi
di trasporto useremo nel futuro quali
saranno le esperienze che proveremo
quali saranno le emozioni che proveremo
nel futuro perché questa ossessione per
il futuro perché io sono stato un
passeggero sono stato un pendolare per
tutto il periodo in cui ho studiato ho
studiato prima padova e poi a treviso
l'esperienza di pendolare è terribile
devi prendere 3 4 mezzi di trasporto per
esempio per andare a treviso io dovevo
andare a piedi fino alla fermata
dell'autobus prendere un piccolo pulmino
fino alla stazione del treno la stazione
del treno poi fino a mestre a mestre
fino a treviso e poi a treviso di nuovo
piedi fino all'università
questo è l'esempio perfetto di
multimodalità che è all'ordine del
giorno è uno dei sistemi con cui la
mobilità del futuro vorrebbe risolvere
tutti i problemi ma questa è la
geometria delle nostre città questa è la
geometria del nostro territorio un
territorio in cui i mezzi pubblici sono
così difficili da rendere efficienti in
un sistema di questo tipo è molto più
probabile essere dei guidatori che non
dei passeggeri perché i mezzi di
trasporto pubblici sono generalmente
troppo distanti dalle nostre case
c'è una grossissima differenza tra la
geometria di queste città e la geometria
di città grandi come tokyo tokyo è
enormemente estesa e densissima per cui
da ogni punto a ogni altro punto ci sarà
sempre una linea della metropolitana a
coprirla in maniera perfetta
però noi dobbiamo risolvere i problemi
delle nostre città le città in cui noi
preferiamo prendere la macchina
impersonale stare ora è dentro il
traffico e lamentarci perché le persone
vicino a noi sono da sole nella loro
macchina esattamente come noi è stato
esattamente nella nostra stessa
direzione perché perché l'alternativa è
prendere un mezzo pubblico prendere un
mezzo pubblico come vi ho detto
significa andare alla fermata
dell'autobus aspettare un numero
indeterminato di minuti poi salire sopra
questo mezzo di trasporto che
generalmente è inquinante vecchissimo e
fare diversi stop anche se non è la mia
fermata per arrivare poi a un punto in
cui quando scendo non sono comunque nel
posto in cui dovrei essere e devo fare
magari altri 10 15 minuti a piedi
insomma non possiamo assolutamente
biasimare le persone che prendono la
macchina privata
la soluzione ideale per evitare anche i
problemi di guidare o di trovare
parcheggio sarebbe usare il taxi se
ognuno di noi potesse permettere solo
ogni mattina prenderemo il taxi sotto
caso e arriveremo al lavoro oppure a
scuola senza dover guidare senza dover
trovare parcheggio ci godremo al nostro
stato di passeggeri e per chi di voi
pensa che questa sia una soluzione
interessante vi do una buonissima
notizia cioè il corso del taxi che
adesso è proibitivo è determinato per il
più del 70 per cento dal costo del
guidatore se noi
eliminiamo il guidatore quindi usiamo la
tecnologia che viene chiamata guida
autonoma tutto quel 70 per cento verrà
ovviamente eliminato ma qual è il
problema perché esiste l'autobus perché
le persone prendono l'autobus è solo una
questione di prezzo
beh non proprio vedete da questa
immagine che una questione importante è
il traffico generato dentro una macchina
per quanto io possa essere passeggero o
guidatore se io sono da solo io occupo
circa 5 metri lineari di strada quindi
io posso occupare una quantità quantità
di strada enorme con lo stesso numero di
passeggeri che invece all'interno di un
autobus occupa solo 30 centimetri quindi
in futuro con taxi a guida autonoma
sarebbe un incubo
impensabile perché nessuno prenderebbe
più l'autobus costa talmente poco
probabilmente costa persino meno
dell'autobus prendere il taxi ognuno di
noi prenderebbe un mezzo di trasporto di
questo tipo
e se invece del taxi noi avessimo un
autobus che fa lo stesso servizio
qual è la discriminante la discriminante
è il fatto che le persone vogliono
essere prese da dove abitano e andare
esattamente dove vogliono andare non
fare fermate intermedie non aspettare
non cambiare da un mezzo a un altro per
arrivare fino a destinazione
è questo il nodo della questione se ci
fosse un autobus che fa la stessa cosa
sono tutti contenti purtroppo tornando
all'immagine di prima il problema è che
nelle nostre città la geometria il fatto
che la periferia e la provincia sono
così sparse e distribuite sul territorio
non permette ai mezzi di questo tipo di
fare questo servizio
questo è quello che succede oggi le
persone partono da casa
poi entrano nelle strade principali
nell'arteria principale che conduce
verso il centro della città e la
intasano completamente e gradualmente
mentre io mi avvicino al centro della
città c'è sempre più traffico però
capite che è solo il primo migliorata il
problema perché le arterie principali
in realtà portano le persone tutte nella
stessa direzione tutte nelle stesse
destinazioni allora quello che abbiamo
diciamo così intuito inventato durante
questa esperienza terribile di
passeggeri di pendolari è stata quella
di dire perché non prendiamo un taxi nel
primo miglio ma successivamente se taxi
di fianco al mio va nella mia stessa
direzione
io salto salto dalla mia macchina alla
macchina dell'altra persona che sta
andando esattamente dove sto andando io
capite dove voglio arrivare
vedete che poi invece di utilizzare tre
macchine per esempio io né utilizzo solo
una perché ho una macchina e altre due
ormai sono state liberate
questa è la descrizione della soluzione
come funziona ovviamente le persone non
possono saltare da un taxi all'altro ma
le persone si possono muovere per
esempio da una stanza all'altra a
tramite una porta che le collega allora
cosa abbiamo fatto abbiamo creato delle
stanzette con le ruote in movimento
questi box che vedete questi pod di
fatto funzionano come se fossero un taxi
nel primo miglio dopodiché quando si
congiungono e si ritrovano sulla strada
principale si uniscono fisicamente si
agganciano tra di loro come se fossero
carrozze di un treno le porte intermedie
si aprono e le persone vanno a sedersi
dov'è il pod che va nella loro
destinazione
una volta arrivati al bivio per esempio
nel caso non stiamo andando nel centro
della città ma in più destinazioni
questi poveri organizzati all'interno
con i passeggeri si dividono e vanno
nelle destinazioni finali come questo
veicolo che aspetto a è sostanzialmente
come vi dicevo una piccola stanzetta
della lunghezza di una smart metà di una
berlina normale e all'interno può
occupare sei persone sedute più quattro
persone in piedi quindi capite che la
densità lineare di persone sulla strada
è enormemente più alta raggiunge gli
stessi livelli di un autobus in ora di
punta ora vi mostro un video che mostra
come l'esperienza dell'utente
all'interno di questo veicolo
vedete che la singola unità il singolo
pod la singola stanzetta viene a
prendermi a casa apre le porte
una volta che le persone sono
all'interno di questa stanzetta di fatto
è come se fossero all'interno di un taxi
per il primo miglio perché la
probabilità di trovare altre persone che
vanno nella stessa direzione e lo stesso
momento è molto bassa quindi per questo
primo pezzettino di strada anche il
costo è sostanzialmente più elevato ma
ricordatevi che siamo in una situazione
di guida autonoma
una volta che ci troviamo sulla strada
principale
qui vedete dubai per esempio il telefono
mi dice attenzione ci siamo per
agganciare con un altro veicolo
le porte appunto si aprono dopo
l'aggancio e il telefonino mi dice dove
andarne il sedere
una volta che io sono andato nel veicolo
in cui ci sono già delle persone che
vanno esattamente nella mia destinazione
li vedete un simpatico giapponese che
prova questa esperienza realtà virtuale
il veicolo di coda si stacca perché si
stacca perché chiaramente adesso è vuoto
non c'è nessun motivo per avere quel
veicolo attaccato a me cosa che invece
succede per esempio negli autobus fuori
dall'ora di punta
io magari 23 persone e poi tutto il
resto dell'autobus è vuoto e quindi ho
centinaia e centinaia di quintali da
portare con me anche se il veicolo è
quasi vuoto che cosa risulta da tutto
questo facendo dei calcoli con questo
sistema
calcoli che sono stati fatti anche dalla
new york university al posto nostro
per garantire la veridicità di quello
che stiamo dicendo abbiamo risultati
incredibili
abbiamo l'ottanta per cento in meno di
traffico chiaramente dovuto anche al
form factor del veicolo
abbiamo ovviamente zero emissioni perché
il veicolo è completamente elettrico ma
soprattutto abbiamo il 300 per cento
abbiamo tre volte la capacità di uno
stesso sistema fatto da veicoli non
modulari cioè che non hanno la capacità
di agganciarsi tra di loro e mescolare
ridistribuire concentrare o distribuire
verso destinazioni diverse i passeggeri
che abbiamo all'interno
ovviamente abbiamo pensato al prezzo
abbiamo pensato alla capacità del
sistema ma abbiamo pensato soprattutto
anche all'esperienza dell'utente
quindi alla comodità a tutti quei
servizi che vorremmo avere quando
passiamo quella mezz'ora quell'ora in
terra della nostra giornata a fare i
pendolari tra casa nostra e lavoro
quindi abbiamo pensato di mettere in
queste stanzette non solo dei passeggeri
dei servizi servizio di qualsiasi tipo
questo è solo un esempio
un esempio in cui vedete una caffetteria
una caffetteria che può essere
interessante non solo ai pendolari ma
per esempio soprattutto ai turisti che
vanno da grosse città come milano a
venezia che fanno il tour di tutta
italia
pensate di vedere all'interno di quei
veicoli dei servizi enogastronomici che
arricchiscono l'esperienza non rendono
semplicemente quelle quattro ore tra
città e città del tempo perso e mi fa
piacere dirvi che tutto quello che vi ho
mostrato è già realtà
abbiamo portato a dubai
questo veicolo
e abbiamo creato due prototipi
funzionanti qui vedete come secam sono
tra di loro in movimento qui vedete gli
interni come sono accoglienti qui vedete
come il veicolo sterza come se fosse un
corpo unico come se fosse una stanza più
grande e non come se fosse un treno con
delle carrozze separate
il fatto di avere quattro ruote
sterzanti permette anche di ruotare su
se stesso quindi permette di andare nei
centri storici con le viuzze più piccole
beh avete capito non dovevo dirlo però è
dubai e perché proprio dubai il perché e
qui vi racconto un simpatico aneddoto lo
sceicco di dubai ha twittato prima
ancora che noi creassimo il veicolo vero
il render che noi avevamo sul sito e
mettendo come frase il futuro dei
trasporti sarà il 30 per cento di
veicoli e guida autonoma nei prossimi
dieci anni
noi ovviamente siamo rimasti stupiti
questo è proprio cascato dal cielo e ci
siamo chiesti ma dobbiamo denunciarlo
dobbiamo essere felici
beh insomma in qualche modo abbiamo
tentato di contattarlo ma era
praticamente impossibile allora cosa
abbiamo fatto abbiamo preso tutti i
possibili concorsi di start up e di
imprese che ci sono nell'area arab di
dubai e abbiamo applicato a tutti i
concorsi beh uno di quei concorsi
l'abbiamo vinto e siamo stati scelti per
andare a presentare allo sceicco e al
ministero dei trasporti di dubai la
nostra innovazione che in quel momento
erano dei prototipi in scala uno a dieci
grandi più o meno così che giravano su
un tappeto nero con delle linee bianche
per terra e abbiamo presentato due volte
allo scico e un'infinità di volte al
ministro dei trasporti per far capire
qual era la nostra innovazione
beh lo sciecco una volta arriva e dice è
fantastico però io lo voglio vedere in
dimensioni reali e quindi da lì abbiamo
firmato un contratto per vendergli è
sostanzialmente i primi due veicoli che
avete visto nel video un anno dopo
abbiamo portato i veicoli appunto che
avete visto abbiamo presentato a uno
degli eventi più grandi che hanno a
dubai ed il dubai world
goldman summit ed è stato un primo passo
per poi andare all'expo 2020 di dubai ma
soprattutto per espandere questa idea in
tutto il mondo un'idea che nasce da un
disagio personale nell'essere passeggero
e che vuole arrivare a creare dei
trasporti che non sono più tempo perso
ma sono in assoluto vita in movimento
grazie
[Applauso]